sin duda Irán no es el mismo país que
hace seis meses cuando maxa mini moría
después de días después de haber sido
capturada por esa policía de la moral en
el centro de Terán por no llevar bien su
vestimenta islámica solamente dos horas
después de haber llegado a esa comisaría
ella sufrió un ataque cerebral y llevada
a este hospital donde moriría días
después esto causó la indignación de
miles y miles de iraníes especialmente
mujeres y especialmente muy jóvenes que
en ese momento se tiraron a la calle a
protestar y sobre todo a pesar de la
represión de las autoridades se quitaron
el velo y empezaron a cantar ese eslogan
que se convirtió en el símbolo de esta
movimiento o esta incluso Revolución
como La llamaron algunos de mujer vida y
libertad del país desde entonces no
solamente ha cambiado en el aspecto
porque muchas de ellas se han quitado
ese velo se lo han dejado caer
especialmente
la ciudad de ciudades en las áreas
urbanas pero también a las autoridades
les ha tocado rebajar la presión contra
ellas se hacen desde la vista gorda
cuando las ven en la calle si ellas no
cantan eslogan y no hacen un Movimiento
Político ellos han dejado de atacar a
las mujeres han intentado volver a
imponer el uso del velo de otras medidas
por ejemplo presionando a los
restaurantes donde mujeres van sin velo
o por ejemplo llamándolas a las
comisarías si las ven en la calle y
captan su imagen entonces luego tienen
que ir a pagar una fianza pero no hay
una presión en la calle y esto después
de haber sido como hablaba una gran
represión con más de 500 personas que
fallecieron en el marco de estas
protestas y miles y miles de ellos
capturados en una amnistía general que
hizo el líder supremo en el marco del
aniversario de la revolución del pasado
11 de febrero más de 20.000 personas
capturadas en estas protestas fueron
liberadas Pero hay muchos de ellos que
continúan en presión especialmente
aquellos que son señalados de tener
relaciones con los países enemigos de
Irán a quienes acusan de estar detrás de
estas protestas entre ellas esas dos
periodistas que sacaron a la luz el caso
de maxa a mini en su momento